ليلة واحدة من
الحرائق والذعر تركت هذه العلامة السوداء
على ليسبوس ، ذهب مخيم المهاجرين في موريا ، وأصبح لدى
بعض الأشخاص الأكثر يأسًا في العالم
الآن أقل من ذلك
عندما زرنا المخيم في وقت سابق من هذا
العام ، فقد رأينا ذلك لأنه كان
يقول الجماعات الإنسانية أن لديك
لنقل الناس من هنا
إلى البر الرئيسي في مكان ما
لتخفيف الضغط هنا على lesbos ، حيث
يبلغ عدد سكان الصالون المترامي الأطراف أكثر من
ثمانية عشر
ألفًا ، التقينا بالعائلات التي لديها القليل من
الصرف الصحي والمياه الغذائية وليس هناك سبب للأمل
هل تعرف كم كانت أيام الأسابيع
13 يومًا 13 يومًا
ماذا  هو أن اسمه
يمشي في مخيم ماوريا للاجئين
هنا
في ليسبوس هو تجربة مواجهة حقًا ،
ربما كان الأمر الأكثر إثارة
للدهشة هو ببساطة
حجم المخيم الذي اختفى ، لكن لا يزال من
الممكن الحصول على إحساس بهذه التجربة حول كيفية
إجبار هؤلاء الأشخاص على ذلك  عش هذا المعرض في
لندن
يشبه آلة الزمن ، فهي تعيدك
بينهم
مرة أخرى في الظروف القذرة المزدحمة
لموريا.
العرض بالتعاون مع CNN هو
جزء من موسم اللاجئين في متحف الحرب الإمبريالية ،
يحيط بك
بالصور والضوضاء الصادرة عن المخيم ،
إنه أداة قوية وغامرة
مصممة للمشي في حذاء
الأشخاص الذين
غالبًا ما يُساء فهم قصصهم
بأن الاتصال البشري هو أيضًا
هدف المعرض الأوسع هنا
والذي  100 عام من الأشخاص الذين فروا
من منازلهم
بسبب الحرب ، لذلك أردنا أن نظهر أن
اللاجئين ليسوا مجرد لاجئين يولدون ، بل
بدأوا
كأشخاص عاديين مع حياة يومية ،
وهم مجبرون على اتخاذ هذه
القرارات الرهيبة المروعة التي
يحتلها أحد الشاشات الطابق بأكمله
من  يستكشف الردهة الشهيرة بالمتحف ،
وهو تاريخ من القنابل للفنان الصيني آي ويوي
، الأجهزة المرعبة التي
تدفع الناس غالبًا لمغادرة منازلهم ،
أخبرني العديد من اللاجئين أنني ما زلت أتذكر
أنهم قالوا إن القنبلة تنزل مثل
حلقة ،
مما يجعلهم
يعتقدون أن هذا أمر لا يصدق.
يمكن أن تنزل القنابل مثل الحلقة
وقد تركت انطباعًا عميقًا في ذهني
مرة أخرى على السحاقيات الذين عاشوا أنا  يجب أن ينام n Moria
قبل الحريق
الآن حيث يمكنهم
أن يغير معرض متحف لندن حياتهم ولكنه
قد يساعد الآخرين على فهم كيفية وصولهم
إلى هناك.